these 76 afghan boys were caught by
turkish soldiers trying to cross the
border
from iran into turkey they had walked
for weeks
relying on smugglers to take them across
the rug mountain terrain
they were desperate to escape the
bombings and fighting in afghanistan
they now face being deported to iran but
they have no regrets and they say they'd
do it all again
if they had a chance of reaching
turkey's big cities
and then maybe onto europe for those who
manage to elude the turkish forces on
the border
and the police in the city it's time to
move on
they split up into smaller groups so as
not to draw attention to themselves
but all have a story to tell
i left college and came here if i stayed
i had to join the war
then my parents said i should leave the
country the taliban recruits young men
you get killed most of these young
afghans have been called by the
smugglers they paid to help them leave
afghanistan
and now they have no money left
we agreed on 750 with the smuggler and
already paid 500
the rest was to be paid when we reached
istanbul
but i had no more money so they left me
on the street
turkey has now ramped up security
measures at its border with iran
these migrants are stationed in
so-called safe houses
the police call them shock houses
waiting for the right moment
to continue their journey the smugglers
take money every day
if the afghans don't pay they get kicked
out there is no escape
doors are locked
i left afghanistan because of war and
misery the taliban are beating and
forcing my parents to cook royal food
for them
and here we are serve two meals a day by
the smuggler
there are about 35 people in this one
house including women and children
there is little air and no privacy
families are reluctant
to talk on camera
we came to turkey to work until the
borders get open then move to europe to
support our family
i worked in iran for six months and have
been here for 10 days
the smuggler says we need to wait here
until the security measures
ease with taliban it is not safe anymore
there is poverty and misery people
cannot pursue their normal lives anymore
in afghanistan
last year 61 asylum seekers on board a
fishing boat died after their boat
capsized in lake
van another 40 migrants have died this
year
this is the cemetery of the nameless the
migrants who wanted to escape bullets
and butchery in their own country
but who fell victim to human traffickers
despite obvious dangers fears are
growing in afghanistan
there will now be many more people who
are prepared to risk their
lives in the hope of finding something
better
elsewhere cinema al jazeera
von turkey